[Musik]
bester österreicher ist dank seiner nähe
zum meer ein erstklassiger standort in
diesem teil dänemark haben wir sehr gute
windverhältnisse die spitze eines 75
meter langen blattes bewegt sich mit 200
kilometern pro stunde
die entwicklung von rotorblättern ist
heutzutage mit elektrischen formel 1
wagen oder raumfahrttechnik vergleichbar
immer wieder verschieden wir die grenzen
des möglichen
[Musik]
eine globale industrielle revolution ist
in vollem gange
der schutz der umwelt und der
bevölkerung unseres planeten stellt uns
vor besondere technologische
herausforderungen
angetrieben von leidenschaftlichen und
engagierten menschen die eine neue welt
gestalten wollen
ich tue es für meine kinder ich bin
davon überzeugt dass das der richtige
weg ist
eine saubere welt
es gibt einen weg raus aus der nutzung
fossiler brennstoffe
eine grünere welt dieser windpark
produziert mehr strom als alle anderen
in großbritannien und wahrscheinlich
sogar in der ganzen welt
was wir bisher gemacht haben wird nicht
mehr reichen es gibt bessere wege wir
müssen jetzt einen schritt weiter gehen
und neue technologien implementieren
gemeinsam bringen sie die
ingenieurskunst voran erschaffen
außergewöhnliche technik zum schutz
unseres planeten für unsere zukunft
[Musik]
die welt tritt in ein neues zeitalter
ein
sichtbarstes zeichen dafür die
windkraftanlage
ob es uns gefällt oder nicht die sanften
riesen werden allmählich zum festen
bestandteil der modernen landschaft
rund um den globus gibt es heute
hunderttausende von turbinen
sie erzeugen mehr als 700 gigawatt strom
genug um fast 500 millionen haushalte zu
versorgen
weil der bedarf wächst und wächst kommen
immer öfter auch die küsten ins spiel
windkraftanlagen im meer zu errichten
ist aber viel schwieriger als an land
wir hatten windböen von 150 kilometern
pro stunde und acht meter hohe wellen
die
chancen aber sind beträchtlich
unbegrenzte mengen an sauberer energie
könnten die fossilen brennstoffe
ersetzen für immer
diese turbinen werden genug saubere
energie für 630.000 haushalte
produzieren hochschule offshore wind
besitzt ein unglaubliches potenzial
kennen die er sämtliche ozeane der welt
für windenergie nutzbar machen hat muss
darum geht
das rennen hat längst begonnen immer
höhere turbinen größere windparks und
konstruktionen die in immer tieferen
mehren den wind einfangen
ein bruchteil des weltweiten windes
würde genügen um die ganze welt mit
strom zu versorgen
[Musik]
turbinen sind der einzige bekannte weg
windenergie zu nutzen sind ist nichts
anderes als luft die sich bewegt und
wenn dinge sich bewegen haben sie
energie aber nicht alles davon vermögen
turbinen einzufangen
denn wenn man den wind energie entzieht
verlangsamt sich die luft
nehme eine turbine 100 prozent der
energie auf würde die luft direkt hinter
den rotorblättern zum stillstand kommen
[Musik]
die luft mauer würde den wind nicht mehr
durchlassen
wissenschaftler haben errechnet dass
maximal 59,3 prozent der energie
gewonnen werden können so besagt es eine
formel des physikers albert bett
an diese grenze wollen ingenieure so nah
wie möglich herankommen und die beste
derzeit bekannte methode sind tragflügel
wie beim flügel eines flugzeugs erzeugt
das tropfenförmige profil auftrieb also
eine kraft die senkrecht zur anströmung
richtung steht
einige turbinen fangen inzwischen fast
50 prozent der windenergie ein und sie
werden immer noch besser
die blätter sind empfindlich bläst der
wind zu stark ändern sie deshalb ihre
neigung und lassen ihn ungehindert durch
[Musik]
bei guten bedingungen treibt der rotor
eine welle im inneren des
maschinenhauses an im generator dreht
sich einen ring aus magneten um eine
metall spule und erzeugt so elektrizität
[Musik]
ende des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts gibt
es bereits viele moderne
windkraftanlagen aber sie sind klein und
teuer
zugleich werden die folgen der nutzung
fossiler brennstoffe immer deutlicher
bietet nicht nur der klimawandel auch
die endlichkeit der fossilen brennstoffe
führte zur suche nach alternativen
möglichkeiten der energieerzeugung
deshalb bereitet sich der energiesektor
seit 20 jahren auf die energiewende vor
die art und weise wie wir energie
erzeugen wird sich komplett ändern
überall schießen windkraftanlagen aus
dem boden aber
verfügbare flächen sind knapp und viele
halten die modernen windräder für eine
verschandelung der landschaft
ein paar pioniere entwickeln eine
mögliche alternative
windparks im meer
auf dem meer gibt es viel mehr wind also
auch viel mehr energie man hat deutlich
mehr platz als ein land weil man nicht
so nahe an den städten ist
aber die bedingungen sind rau und
gefährlich manch einer bezweifelt dass
offshore windparks überhaupt machbar
sind
die große frage war ob die technologie
in dieser feindseligen umgebung mitten
im meer vor der wind am stärksten wird
zuverlässig und stabil sein kann
und natürlich ob sich das ganze
überhaupt finanzieren lässt
geschäftsführer für offshore-windkraft
beim energieunternehmen iberdrola ist
entschlossen einen weg zu finden mit
einem kleinen team entwickelten wir eine
strategie für den einstieg in die
offshore windkraft wir erkannten dass
der sektor riesiges potenzial besorgen
vorausgesetzt man produziert im großen
industriellen maßstab
als vision riesige windparks auf dem
meer sollen nach und nach mit fossilen
brennstoffen betriebene kraftwerke
ersetzen und schließlich die ganze welt
mit sauberer energie versorgen
um das zu erreichen muss er die
produktionskosten für offshore-windkraft
senken der preis muss nicht nur mit
anderen erneuerbaren energiequellen
konkurrieren können sondern auch mit
kohle und gas
2010 beginnt kohl mit der planung eines
riesigen windparks er will beweisen dass
seine idee funktioniert vor der
südenglischen küste findet er den
idealen ort
eine reihe von großen gas und
kohlekraftwerken stand kurz vor der
stilllegung
das vereinigte königreich musste mehr
als die hälfte seiner energie
infrastruktur neu aufbauen
als insel verfügt das land über einen
langen küstenstreifen mit jeder menge
wind alles passte perfekt so die energie
wurde tatsächlich benötigt und die
nötigen ressourcen dafür lang direkt vor
der haustür
das projekt erhält den namen ist eng an
der windpark soll weitaus größer werden
als alle damals existierenden
der bau der kolossalen anlage stellt
kohls team vor große herausforderungen
[Musik]
die turbinen müssen leistungsstärker
sein als alles was auf dem markt ist die
fundamente stehen in 45 meter tiefem
wasser
102 gigantische turbinen verteilt auf
einer fläche von 300 quadratkilometern
[Musik]
und nicht zuletzt bedarf es einer
leitung die den strom zur fast 50
kilometer entfernten küste transportiert
der riesige windparks soll genug energie
liefern um ein typisches kohlekraftwerk
zu ersetzen und das zu einem günstigeren
preis
wie petit mit unseren teams wollten wir
sicherstellen dass east anglia nicht nur
das größte projekt der welt sein würde
sondern auch das kosteneffizienteste
[Musik]
april 2017 auf werften in spanien
nordirland und den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten beginnen hunderte
von metall arbeitern mit dem bau der
fundamente genannt jackets
die firma halten die turbinen über
wasser sie werden mit langem tief in den
meeresboden getrieben empfehlen
befestigt die strukturen müssen extrem
stabil sein sie müssen nicht nur die
über 400 tonnen schweren turbinen tragen
sondern auch der stürmischen see und dem
enormen druck des windes standhalten
für die kosten ist projektleiter charlie
jordan verantwortlich für ihn spielt
nicht nur die herstellung der gewaltigen
konstruktionen eine rolle auch der
transport ist ein faktor
[Musik]
ein großer teil der kosten entfällt auf
transport und lagerung die wollten wir
so niedrig wie möglich halten das gelang
uns vor allem mit hilfe eines
innovativen jacket designs
jackets haben normalerweise vierbeiner
jordans team erkannte dass mehr jackets
auf ein transportschiff passen wenn man
eines der beine entfernt das reduziert
die kosten schlecht aber auch die
struktur
[Musik]
wird das gewicht nur noch von 3 statt
von vier beinen getragen ist die
konstruktion nichts mehr starken
was sie also tun müssen ist das material
zu verstärken
diese aufgabe übernimmt die werft in der
die jacket fehle hergestellt werden
jeder fall besteht aus bis zu 19
zusammengeschweißten stahlrollen und
wiegt 120 tonnen
[Musik]
die ingenieure berechnen dass eine
verbreiterung der pfähle um 150
millimeter nötig ist um die zusätzliche
last auf den meeresboden zu übertragen
das macht die gesamtstruktur stabil
genug
[Musik]
die riesigen jackets können also auch
auf drei beinen stehen
[Musik]
während die arbeiter 845 tonnen stahl
montieren wächst jeder der riesigen
türme auf eine höhe von 65 metern
[Musik]
allein in spanien investieren über 1000
menschen eine million stunden
arbeitszeit in die fundamente
um die konstruktion zu vervollständigen
wird ein letztes elementares bauteil
benötigt es verbindet die jackets mit
den turbinen
die stählernen ringer werden pflanze
genannt sie müssen extrem stabil sein
und absolut passgenau
um den ring so stark zu machen dass er
das gewicht einer turbine halten kann
werden die komponenten bei hohen
temperaturen geschmiedet gar nicht so
einfach so die exakte größe
hinzubekommen
es liegt in der natur des staates dass
er sich beim erhitzen und abkühlen
ausdehnt und zusammenzieht
deshalb müssen wir während des
herstellungsprozesses gewährleisten dass
die ringe mit einer toleranz von wenigen
millimetern reduziert werden
beim schmieden der riesigen ringer wird
der stahl auf eine temperatur von über
1000 grad celsius erhitzt
anschließend wird er gewalzt und in form
gebracht
die pflanze müssen einen durchmesser von
genau 6000 zwei millimetern haben aber
metall schrumpft wenn es abkühlt
die berechnungen müssen also exakt sein
denn es gibt nur einen versuch
das team hat fantastische arbeit
geleistet wenn wir das fundament mit der
turbine verbinden gibt es keine lücken
eine solide verbindung
nach einem jahr sind die fundamente
bereit für den einsatz in der nordsee
die drei beinen konstruktion erlaubt es
wie geplant mehr jackets auf die
transportschiffe zu laden
[Musik]
die dreibeinige bauweise hat uns große
vorteile gebracht sie ist enorm
platzsparend und erleichtert die montage
mit jeder tour konnten wir so mehr
jackets transportieren und installieren
da einige der schiffe 19.000 kilometer
rund um die südspitze afrikas
zurücklegen müssen entlastet jeder
eingesparte vaters budget für charlie
jordan ein großer ökonomischer erfolg
und die jackets sind unterwegs
[Musik]
in der nordsee geht es nun los mit der
installation der fundamente
[Musik]
als erstes werden die tragenden pfeiler
aufgestellt und in den meeresboden
gerammt
[Musik]
dann werden die decke herabgelassen und
an den vielen befestigt
[Musik]
die fundamente sind bereit für die
windturbinen
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit muss das team ein
sogenanntes offshore umspannwerk
errichten
die riesige maschine soll in der mitte
des windparks stehen sie sammelt die
gesamte elektrizität aus den turbinen
und schickt sie zur küste
das umspannwerk ist das herzstück des
offshore-windparks hier laufen die an
die turbinen angeschlossenen leitungen
die arterien zusammen
das ist englisch umspannwerk muss die
spannung zunächst von 66 auf 220
kilovolt erhöhen dann schickt es die
energie über eine am meeresboden
liegende leitung zu einem umspannwerk an
land dort wird der strom ins netz
eingespeist
[Musik]
die ruhe spannung ermöglicht eine
effektivere übertragung unterwegs geht
also weniger energie verloren
der größte offshore windpark der welt
benötigt allerdings auch ein nie
dagewesenes umspannwerk
wir wollten so viel grüne energie wie
möglich produzieren eine zentrale rolle
spielte dabei das offshore umspannwerk
wir haben bei unseren planungen die
technisch machbare größe voll ausgereizt
spanien sommer 2017
der bau des überdimensionalen
umspannwerks ist in vollem gange
ebenso wie der des gigantischen jackets
dass es über wasser halten sollen
[Musik]
mit fast 4000 tonnen ist es das größte
je gebaute seiner art das bringt neue
herausforderungen mit sich
[Musik]
es gab weltweit nur zwei schiffe die in
der lage waren so eine struktur zu
installieren
sie drei jahre im voraus für einen
zweiwöchigen slot buchen also noch vor
baubeginn
den slot darf das team keinesfalls
verpassen sonst drohen verzögerungen und
hohe zusatzkosten
alles muss strikt nach plan laufen
als erstes bauteil soll das jacket
fundamente an die englische küste
verschifft werden
doch bei der ausfahrt aus dem spanischen
hafen wartet ein mächtiges hindernis
die brücke über die bucht von cadiz hat
eine lichte höhe von 69 metern
obwohl sie zu den höchsten brücken
europas zählt sind die fundamente auf
dem transportschiff noch höher
gleich hinter der hafen ausfahrt liegt
eine brücke darunter passte unsere
ladung bei normalem wasserstand nicht
durch
es gibt nur eine lösung um die brücke zu
meistern muss das schiff den tiefsten
wasserstand abpassen
[Musik]
schon mal damit anzusehen wie die
riesige konstruktion mit so winzigen
abstand unter der brücke durchfuhr war
ein ziemlich schweißtreibender moment
kurz darauf wird auch das
rekordverdächtige umspannwerk verschifft
nicht mehr lange dann wird es im herzen
des windparks installiert
die 2000 kilometer lange reise beginnt
in spanien führt an portugal vorbei und
durch den ärmelkanal in die nordsee
pünktlich trifft die mobile anlage ein
und das vorbestellte kranschiff wartet
schon
die installation kann beginnen
das sind riesige schiffe mit fast 10.000
tonnen und einer länge von knapp 200
meter das umspannwerk selbst liegt fast
4000 tonnen das muss man erst mal
anheben
aber vorsicht das gewicht des
umspannwerks könnte reichen um das kran
schiff zum kentern zu bringen
damit das nicht passiert kommen 30.000
tonnen ballast in den laderaum
das dreifache gewicht des eiffelturms
juni startete seien bei der planung geht
es nicht nur um die position der
umspannstation das schiff braucht selbst
auch stabilisierenden ballast damit es
die aktion durchführen kann
[Musik]
das umspannwerk ist endlich an seinem
platz
als nächstes muss es an das englische
stromnetz angeschlossen werden
dafür wird ein 85 kilometer langes kabel
auf dem meeresboden verlegt
die klippen werden für die leitung
untertunnelt
[Musik]
dann folgt ein 37 kilometer langer
graben bis zum nächsten umspannwerk
[Musik]
dort wird der strom aus dem windpark ins
nationale netz eingespeist
jetzt ist alles bereit für die turbinen
als das team im jahr 2010 mit der
planung beginnt produzieren die größten
turbinen der welt gerade mal fünf
megawatt strom
genug um zum beispiel jeden tag 3000
durchschnittliche elektroautos
aufzuladen
für günstigeren strom aber müssen
leistungsfähigere turbinen her das
bedeutet viel größere rotoren als damals
verfügbar sind
als wir die windturbinen für das east
anglia wohnprojekt auswählten gab es ein
organ sie existierten nur auf dem papier
sie waren größer als alles was man im
bereich der erneuerbaren energien je
gesehen hatte
ein team in dänemark erhält den auftrag
den plan in die tat umzusetzen
österreich dänemark
im windigen flachland unweit der nordsee
stehen einige der größten
windkraftanlagen der welt
obwohl an land sind die gigantischen
türme eigentlich für den einsatz auf see
vorgesehen
offshore windturbinen werden immer
größer und hier werden sie auf herz und
nieren getestet
so auch die für ist eng an bestimmten
[Musik]
wo wir spielen vom frühen konzept ist
zum detaillierten design den gesamten
prozess mit computermodellen durch aber
das genügt nicht wir brauchen auch den
test unter realen bedingungen
jeppe von kirkegaard leitet die rotoren
konstruktionsabteilung des weltweit
größten herstellers von offshore
turbinen siemens k mi sa
im jahr 2015 muss er beweisen dass die
turbine tatsächlich die prognostizierte
strommenge erzeugt
in der windindustrie sind die margen
extrem knapp kalkuliert
im schlimmsten fall produziert die
turbine ein oder zwei prozent weniger
als wir versprochen haben das würde den
businessplan des kunden torpedieren und
sich letztlich auf die gesamte
gesellschaft negativ auswirken
kirkegaard soll ein rotor konstruieren
der über 50 prozent mehr strom erzeugt
um ihn leistungsfähiger zu machen werden
die rotorblätter von 63 metern auf
sagenhafte 75 meter verlängert
die frage lautet welchen einfluss hat
das auf gewicht und kosten
bei nur 25 prozent zusätzlicher länge
hätte die masse ohne den einsatz neuer
technologien um etwa 50 prozent
zugenommen ein schwereres rotorblatt
braucht eine schwerere name eine schwere
gondel einen massiveren turm und das
treibt die kosten aus technischer sicht
besteht die herausforderung also darin
die gewichtszunahme in engen grenzen zu
halten
kirkegaard team muss die rotorblätter
komplett neu konstruieren sie sollen
länger sein aber möglichst kaum schwerer
das aber ist riskant denn je länger ein
rotorblatt desto anfälliger ist es bei
starkem wind
kirkegaard wählt einen radikal neuen
ansatz
bei dem neuen design ließen wir uns von
vögeln inspirieren insbesondere von
möwen
deren flügel sind besonders flexibel
biegsam sie nehmen die kraft des windes
auf ohne zu brechen
unser ziel war dass die flügel sich
gleichzeitig bieten und drehen und so
die windenergie aufnehmen
[Musik]
ein völlig neues hoch flexibles
rotorblatt also starke böen können es
zwar biegen aber nicht brechen
trotzdem bleibt die gefahr dass genau
das ab einer bestimmten wind intensität
geschieht
der trick besteht darin dass sich das
blatt zwar wiegt aber auch gleichzeitig
vom wind wegdreht das reduziert die
belastung und bewahrt das blatt vor
schaden
mit dem verringerung der belastung
ermöglicht es das blatt bei gleichem
gewicht zu verlängern
jetzt geht es an die umsetzung wird das
neue design funktionieren
jedes der riesigen blätter ist
handgefertigt
zuerst werden mehrere tonnen glasfaser
in eine riesige form eingebracht sie
verleihen dem blatt seine festigkeit
die platten werden in einem speziellen
winkel angeordnet der später die drehung
ermöglicht
dann folgt eine schicht aus balsaholz
das ist steif aber auch leicht
denn wie dann spritzen wir acht tonnen
epoxid als ein sozusagen den klebstoff
der das blatt zusammenhält auf der
ganzen welt gibt es keine größeren
bauteile aus einem stück als unsere
rotorblätter
[Musik]
eine reihe von tests bestätigt dass sich
die neue bauform wie vorgesehen biegt
und verdreht aber
wird sie auch die angekündigte menge an
energie erzeugen
[Musik]
schließlich werden die 75 meter langen
blätter zum ersten mal eingesetzt
die größte turbine der welt
[Musik]
auf dem testgelände in österreich wird
die windgeschwindigkeit mit
meteorologischen equipment gemessen
so kann die leistung der turbinen exakt
ins verhältnis zur jeweiligen
windgeschwindigkeit gesetzt werden dazu
kommt das feintuning der turbine
die tests dauern geschlagene drei jahre
und zur kirche ganz großer freude werden
die erwartungen übertroffen um ein
prozent
das klingt wenig ist tatsächlich aber
eine bedeutende steigerung bei einem
windpark mit 100 turbinen bekommt man
quasi eine turbine dazu
die größte windturbine der welt hat den
test mit bravour bestanden
jetzt ist sie bereit in einem der
größten windparks der welt eingesetzt zu
werden
[Musik]
great wall of england
bis zum sommer 2009 10 werden hier die
riesigen komponenten montiert
insgesamt 102 windturbinen
[Musik]
das war ein ziemlicher trip fünf jahre
arbeite ich jetzt schon hier das ist ein
großer moment zu sehen wie alles
wirklichkeit trifft
die erste ladung kommt aufs schiff und
ich bin dabei
der höhepunkt des projekts darauf haben
wir alle gewartet
die turbinen zählen zu den größten und
leistungsstärksten die je gebaut wurden
[Musik]
jeder turm ist so hoch wie ein
fußballfeld lang ist
jedes blatt übertrifft die spannweite
einer boeing 747
[Musik]
und in den maschinen häusern den
sogenannten gondeln hätten zwei londoner
doppeldecker busse platz
vier im hafen von great giana fanden
sämtliche turbinen komponenten
jeder hand gefertigt und bereit aufs
schiff gebracht und installiert zu
werden
dann haben wir die gondeln das
eigentliche herz der windkraftanlage sie
wurden in deutschland gebaut
[Musik]
die türme kommen aus ganz europa spanien
schottland dänemark sie kamen per schiff
und werden jetzt verladen wir bringen
sie raus zum offshore windpark dort
werden sie aufgebaut bis alle 102
windturbinen steht
komplett mit sockel ist jede turbine
doppelt so hoch wie die new yorker
freiheitsstatue
bei voller leistung versorgt eine
turbine über 6000 haushalte
kontinuierlich mit strom
wenn dieses projekt abgeschlossen ist
werden die 102 turbinen genug saubere
energie produzieren um 630.000 haushalte
zu versorgen
für installation und wartung braucht es
hochqualifizierte arbeitskräfte
vor allem müssen sie gewappnet sein für
die rauen bedingungen in der nordsee
[Musik]
während der wintermonate beträgt die
überlebenszeit im wasser nur wenige
minuten
kurs ist die sicherheit steht bei uns
ganz oben jeder der hier raus kommt
arbeitet unter extremen bedingungen
offshore windpark ist harte arbeit auf
eine echte herausforderung das beginnt
schon morgens mit dem weg zur arbeit
die sicherheit kann nur gewährleistet
werden wenn das team auf alles
vorbereitet ist
[Musik]
das bedeutet intensives training
in der küstenstadt loosdorf bildet
rettungsschwimmers kein cloud in die
nachwuchs aus
ich bin sehr leidenschaftlich wenn es
darum geht die leute vorzubereiten jeder
soll in einem stück nach hause kommen
falls mal was schiefgeht bewahren
der trainings pohl simuliert die wind-
und wellenbedingungen die die angehenden
techniker in der nordsee erwartet
die jungen rekruten sollen die east
anglia turbinen langfristig installieren
und warten
[Musik]
ich mache eine ausbildung zum
instandhaltungs techniker das beinhaltet
praktisch alles was in einem windpark zu
tun ist von der installation bis zur
wartung für mich wird der windpark
wahrscheinlich einen job fürs leben
in dem fünfwöchigen kurs lernen die
auszubildenden überlebenstechniken für
den notfall auf hoher see
[Musik]
wichtiger noch als das körperliche
training ist die richtige mentale
einstellung es geht nicht nur um
informationsvermittlung sie sollen auch
ihre wahrnehmung schärfen ihre
nackenhaare sollen sich aufrichten und
sie sollen bereit sein dann wirklich mal
was schiefgeht so wir achten vor allem
auf die kleinen dinge und wir treiben
sie hart an
[Applaus]
bald schon sind die azubis bereit für
den windpark der vor der küste gestalt
annimmt
[Applaus]
die turbinen teile sind unterwegs zu
ihrem endgültigen bestimmungsort
bislang liegt das unternehmen voll im
zeit- und kostenplan
das spezialschiff eine schwimmende
plattform steht mit seinen vier beinen
in 45 metern tiefe fest auf dem
meeresboden
die wellen können ihm nichts anhaben die
arbeit kann beginnen
[Musik]
hinter mir sehen wir dc ins tor sie baut
die turbinen zusammen
im moment richtet sie gerade den turm
auf
danach kommt die gondel dran
zum schluss werden die drei flügel
installiert
das ganze dauert rund 14 stunden
entscheidend ist dass das team den
zeitplan einhält
bring dir in die offshore leistung ich
während der offshore bauphase sollte es
möglichst keine verzögerungen geben
schließlich sind dabei die teuren
installationsschiffe im einsatz und die
sind nur für eine begrenzte zeit gebucht
bevor sie zum nächsten projekt weiter
kräftig und es ist also wirklich wichtig
sich an dem geplanten ablauf zu halten
[Musik]
installationsschiffe kosten pro tag etwa
150.000 euro da geht jede verzögerung
mächtig ins geld aber 13 turbinen sind
bereits installiert die operation in
fahrt auf
das schiff hat vier komplette turbinen
an bord
damit fertig fährt es zurück in den
hafen um neue komponenten zu holen
bis jetzt ist alles gut gelaufen
wir hatten keine pannen und liegen gut
in der zeit
doch auf den sommer folgen herbst und
winter der wind nimmt zu und das heben
der komponenten wird immer schwieriger
eine besondere herausforderung sind die
flügel sie sind 75 meter lang und so
konzipiert dass sie den wind einfachen
bei sturm sind die rotorblätter deshalb
am anfälligsten
im jahr 2019 erlebt ist eng an einen der
stürmischsten winter aller zeiten
ende 2009 10 anfang 2020 hatten wir
einige außergewöhnliche wetterlagen
einmal zogen innerhalb von drei wochen
drei große stürme durch
ist der wind zu heftig werden
sicherheitshalber die arbeiten
eingestellt damit keine unfälle
passieren um den zeitplan einhalten zu
können hat charlie jordan noch ein ass
im ärmel
wir konnten ein zweites schiff zu buchen
und damit die kapazität um 100 prozent
erhöhen
wann immer die äußeren bedingungen es
erlaubten haben wir die leistungen der
installation entsprechend maximiert
so kommt das team bei gutem wetter zügig
voran trotz mancher unterbrechung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
elfter juli 2020 die letzte turbine wird
das britische netz angeschlossenen der
windpark hat eine kapazität von 7 114
megawatt
und versorgt mehr als 600.000 haushalte
mit strom
[Musik]
du verbringst all die zeit damit die
teile zusammen zu setzen aber wenn die
anlage dann endlich steht die turbinen
in betrieb sind und alles einwandfrei
funktioniert ist das ein fantastischer
erfolg
eine erstaunliche leistung ein tolles
gefühl nicht nur für mich sondern auch
für hunderte von menschen die am projekt
beteiligt war
der windpark ist im zeitplan geblieben
und unterhalb des budgets
ein beweis dafür dass offshore
windenergie wettbewerbsfähig ist
zwei drittel der erdoberfläche sind mit
wasser bedeckt da müsste der
offshore-windkraft eigentlich eine
blühende zukunft bevorstehen aber das
wachstum wird durch einen entscheidenden
faktor begrenzt
offshore windkraft ist vor allem im
flachwasser gebieten erfolgreich
aber in vielen teilen der welt wie an
der westküste der vereinigten staaten in
südamerika und teilen asiens gibt es die
einfach nicht
dort muss eine andere lösung her
untersuchungen haben ergeben dass 95
prozent der weltmeere zu tiefe jacket
fundamente sind die zukunft der offshore
windkraft könnte sich also auf eine
handvoll küsten standorte beschränken es
sei denn ein völlig neuer ansatz wird
gefunden
[Musik]
eine mögliche lösung wird während einer
norwegischen regatta im jahr 2001
ersonnen zwei ingenieure knut soll berg
und da christen sind sind beim segeln
als ihnen eine schwimmende boje aufhält
sie bemerken dass es sich dabei um eine
extrem stabile struktur handelt
[Musik]
ein seil zieht die boje nach unten
die auftriebskraft zieht sie nach oben
die beiden gegensätzlichen kräfte führen
dazu dass sie stets in die vertikale
position zurückkehrt die beiden segler
fragen sich ob das gleiche prinzip nicht
auch für eine schwimmende windturbine
gelten könnte
anstelle des strafen halteseil es zieht
ballast sie richtung meeresboden
während die luft darüber für auftrieb
sorgt und sie nach oben zieht
schwimmende turbinen könnten fast
überall im ozean platziert werden aber
können sie auch einem sturm trotzen
ingenieursteam in boxes wird
hinzugezogen um das herauszufinden
anfangs bestand meine aufgabe darin
anhand von simulationen zu zeigen das
schwimmende turbinen auch einen schweren
hurrikan überstehen können
dabei stellten wir fest dass die
strukturen stark hin und her schaukelt
der neigungswinkel betrug bis zu 20 grad
also ziemlich viel
wir gingen aber davon aus dass die
standard turbinen die wir auf die
schwimmende struktur setzen wollten
nicht mehr als zehn grad aushalten würde
für größere stabilität muss der
schwerpunkt nach unten versetzt werden
die forscher versuchen es mit einem
langen zylindrischen tank und sehr
dichten ballast
schließlich finden sie ein
funktionierendes design jedenfalls in
der theorie hat
[Musik]
uns sehr inspiriert wir waren so
glücklich wie ein ingenieur nur sein
kann
fehlt nur noch der beweis dass die
schwimmende turbine auch im großen
maßstab und unter realen bedingungen
funktioniert
15 jahre später nach jahrelangen tests
mit miniaturen entstehen in spanien
bauteile für den weltweit ersten
schwimmenden windpark
absolute präzision ist dabei pflicht
[Musik]
ein schwimmendes fundament mit beulen
oder dellen könnte unter dem druck der
natürlichen kräfte und wann leck
schlagen und sinkt
die fertigen mega bojen sind über 90
meter langen 14 meter breit und wiegen
mehr als 2000 tonnen
die riesigen stahl tanz werden auf
schiffe geladen
und zum 2000 kilometer entfernten
montage ort gebracht
im mai 2017 erreichen die schwimmenden
unterkonstruktionen den harder fjord in
norwegen
jetzt geht es an den ballast
während zwei schlepper den gelben riesen
in position halten pumpt ein drittes
boot wasser in sein inneres
aber wasser allein genügt nicht
mit wasser als ballast liegt der
schwerpunkt nicht tief genug
die struktur wäre zu instabil für starke
windböe
[Musik]
immerhin sorgt das wasser dafür dass ein
ende nach unten sinkt 80 meter tief
dann wird eisenerz eingefüllt es ist
fünf mal dichter als wasser verlegt den
schwerpunkt der struktur weiter nach
unten und macht sie stabiler am ende
sind es 5000 tonnen eisenerz und 3000
tonnen wasser das ergebnis ist eine
außerordentlich stabile basis
bereit die erste schwimmende
windkraftanlage der welt zu tragen
das gesamtgewicht einer schwimmenden
turbine wird 12.000 tonnen betragen etwa
so viel wie 2008 kanisch elefanten
im nahe gelegenen hafen von stored sind
sämtliche turbinen komponenten
aufgereiht
der fjord ist 900 meter tief und vor
unwetter geschützt aber selbst in diesem
umfeld ist der bau einer windkraftanlage
mit schwimmenden fundamenten alles
andere als ein kinderspiel
[Musik]
deshalb werden die turbinen zunächst an
land montiert
[Musik]
erst dann werden sie mit den
schwimmenden fundamenten verbunden
so hohe turbinen sind noch nie in einem
stück angehoben worden und es gibt nur
zwei schiffe auf der welt die dafür groß
genug sind
die schiffe sind extrem teuer da darf
man keine zeit verlieren es muss einfach
funktionieren wenn wir die turbine
draufsetzen muss die position perfekt
die beiden monster kräne der 7000 heben
die 170 meter turbine in die höhe
noch nie zuvor ist so ein manöver
versucht worden
es verlangt dem team alles ab
äußerste präzision ist gefragt und so
dauert es stunden bis die erste turbine
auf dem sockel landet
monika petersen ist die montage leiterin
ich werde ganz emotional da steckt so
viel arbeit drin
im letzten moment stoppt er kann etwas
schief zu laufen
die sind schon so weit gekommen
sie wollen auch jetzt nicht umkehren
trotz seiner größe kann sich das monster
shift punktgenau bewegen
ein hoch modernes dynamisches
positionierungssystem
nutzt 12 schub düsen um das schiff in
position zu halten
sie versuchen es noch mal
schauen sie es sieht gut aus
ja ja ja ja
erstaunlich jetzt haben wir es
der kritischste moment des ganzen
projekts wir haben es geschafft sie ist
an ihrem platz fantastisch jetzt haben
wir bewiesen dass es funktioniert
nach vielen stunden ist die turbine
endlich mit der spendenbasis verbunden
eine weltneuheit
das hat richtig spaß gemacht was war der
aufregendste moment im ganzen projekt
jetzt muss nur noch das wetter
mitspielen dann machen wir gleich weiter
mit den nächsten 4
[Musik]
in den nächsten tagen folgen vier
weitere turbinen alles geht glatt
die riesigen strukturen sind mit 253
metern mehr als dreimal so hoch wie der
transatlantik liner queen mary 2
[Musik]
80 meter davon verbergen sich unter der
oberfläche
dann eine weitere weltpremiere
die komplett montierten windturbinen
werden übers meer geschleppt
wegen des luftwiderstands beträgt die
reisegeschwindigkeit nur fünf kilometer
pro stunde so dauert die reise nach
schottland geschlagene fünf tage
september 2020
die schottische stadt peter heidt hat
eine besondere attraktion
mit dem boot dauert es vom hafen aus
eine stunde bis zum einzigen
schwimmenden windpark der welt
seit drei jahren erzeugen die turbinen
nun schon strom für die stadt
das ist halloween scotland der erste
schwimmende offshore windpark der welt
das gebiet von peta hat eignet sich
hervorragend für einen windpark wie sie
sehen bläst es hier ganz schön sehr
gleichmäßige wind eine konventionelle
anlage könnten sie hier nicht bauen
dafür ist dass mehr zu tief für
schwimmende turbinen ist es perfekt
mit bloßem auge ist der unterschied
zwischen einer schwimmenden und einer
konventionellen turbine kaum zu erkennen
der einzige unterschied ist die leichte
vertikale neigung man erkennt sie wenn
man genau hinschaut
sonja chirico in repo leitet die anlage
es ist ihre aufgabe die leistung der
schwimmenden turbinen zu überwachen
wir überprüfen den output aber auch wie
sich die raue umgebung auf die turbinen
auswirkt
der windpark wurde so konzipiert dass er
harry caine standhalten kann und die
stunde der wahrheit kommt schneller als
erwartet
der windpark wurde im oktober 2017 in
betrieb genommen nur wenige tage später
zog hurrikan ophelia auf
da waren wir natürlich alle sehr besorgt
der sturm trifft die turbinen mit voller
wucht leiden sie sich um mehr als zehn
grad kann der druck sie beschädigen
als die windgeschwindigkeit 90 kilometer
pro stunde erreicht schalten sich die
rotoren ab
so bleiben die turbinen vor den starken
böen geschützt auch die wellen können
dem schwimmenden fundament nichts
anhaben
[Musik]
die turbinen haben bewiesen dass sie
unter solchen bedingungen bestehen
können
sie verhielten sich genau wie erwartet
die schwimmenden strukturen halten den
äußeren bedingungen also stand aber
erzeugen sie auch genauso viel strom wie
konventionelle windturbinen
nach der dreijährigen testphase sprechen
die ergebnisse für sich
[Musik]
mit heimen scotland wollten wir zeigen
das einschwimmen der windpark genauso
viel energie erzeugen kann wie ein
traditionell boden gebunden
tatsächlich ist das so in die ddr
produziert sogar noch mehr weil wir ihn
in gebieten mit stärkeren wind
platzieren können
dieser windpark liefert mehr strom ins
netz als alle windparks der welt
in der zwischenzeit sind die
konventionellen windparks weiter auf dem
vormarsch denn die kosten sinken
[Musik]
die produktionskosten für offshore strom
sind innerhalb von zehn jahren um zwei
drittel gesunken
windenergie ist heute günstiger als
strom aus gas kohle oder atomkraft
dank seiner offshore-windparks kommt
großbritannien im jahr 2020 zum ersten
mal seit der industriellen revolution
zwei monate lang ohne kohle energie aus
die offshore industrie liefert aber
nicht nur erschwinglichen und sauberen
strom sie sorgt auch für
gesellschaftlichen wandel
die industrie coach profile küstenstädte
waren früher stark von der öl und
gasproduktion geprägt
seit 20 30 jahren gibt es dort immer
weniger arbeit
vielen arbeitern in der region die
früher im öl und gassektor tätig waren
eröffnen die windparks neue
möglichkeiten
[Musik]
nicht im micky das schöne an der
offshore windkraft ist dass wir den
küstenstädten neues leben einhauchen
konnte
durch durch die notwendigen ingenieur
arbeiten an den offshore windprojekten
brachten wir wieder jobs in die häfen
gleichzeitig profitiert die offshore
windindustrie von den qualifizierten
arbeitskräften die bereit waren für uns
zu arbeiten und uns zu helfen das
potenzial der offshore windkraft zu
nutzen
schon jetzt sind noch größere windparks
und noch größere turbinen geplant der
jüngste prototyp hat 107 meter lange
blätter jede umdrehung des riesigen
rotors versorgt einen haushalt zwei tage
lang mit strom
manche experten glauben dass offshore
windparks das potenzial haben den
weltweiten strombedarf bis 2040 um das
elffache zu übertreffen
[Musik]
so wie die offshore windparks haben
bewiesen dass in der lage sind in großem
stil sauberen grünen zuverlässigen und
erschwinglichen strom zu produzieren
die sweet crude solche projekte lassen
sich ziemlich schnell in großem maßstab
realisieren das schafft eine menge
lokaler vorteile in zehn jahren wird
fast jede region mit einer küstenlinie
diese vorteile nutzen
deshalb hat offshore wind so viel
potenzial für unsere künftige
stromversorgung
der offshore windkraft gehört die
zukunft
[Musik]